I want to talk to you today about the
continued Scandal surrounding lying
Republican Congressman George Santos and
what is now it's not even really an
alleged past as a drag queen and I know
that the term Queen is it appropriate is
it not I I don't really know now before
I dive into the topic I want to start
with I don't care about drag queens in
the sense that I don't believe drag
queens are a danger to children I don't
believe drag queens are a prominent or
important political social cultural or
economic issue to be describing or
talking about I just to me drag queens
are a non-issue Republicans have made
drag queens an issue claiming some of
the things I just said I don't believe
claiming as Republicans have that
putting together children and drag
queens is dangerous to the children in
some way
um working to get drag queen story hours
of different kinds where men dressed in
drag read stories to kids
um they have made it a political issue
and have claimed that there is a
fundamental immorality to drag queens
and now it turns out that lying
Republican Congressman George Santos
regularly dressed in drag now I don't
know if there is a pejorative
connotation to saying drag queen I don't
know if there's a difference between
dressing in drag regularly and being a
quote drag queen I don't know the
difference but it seems to me that
George Santos was a drag queen for a
period of Time Business Insider now
reports George Santos partied in drag
over a three-year period new videos
appear to show despite a suggestion it
was a one-off I want you to remember
he initially said it's not him in the
pictures when these pictures came out of
Santos reportedly dressed in drag it's
not me more recently he said
it's me I did it once I had fun so sue
me but now videos and photos spanning a
three-year period 2005 to 2008 appear to
show Santos in a drag Persona he went by
the name Katara so we are now we've got
George Santos we have Anthony devolder
now we have Katara which was his drag
character George Anthony Katara Santos
de volder
um they have been fear-mongering against
the LGBT community they have been
fear-mongering about drag queens and now
it turns out that one of their own who
they are very hesitant to just condemn
and say this guy is such a liar he
shouldn't resign he just he should
resign members of Congress have not been
doing that in any significant numbers
they now are saying nothing about it and
the story first broke last week when
freelance journalist Marissa kabus
published a sub-stack post about the
drag queen past of George Santos and it
included the pictures and testimony of
friends and all of it and even in the
follow-up of this story George Santos
continued to lie first saying it wasn't
him then saying he did it once and then
now we have evidence that he was
regularly dressing in drag I don't care
that George Santos dressed in drag I
don't care what I care about is he lies
about everything everything and of
course the selective outrage from
Republicans about if and when he's doing
the right thing or the wrong thing
versus when it's Democrats is
disappointing it's disgusting and it's
pathetic so yeah I'm disappointed that
there are more lies but it's also
important to call out their hypocrisy
and I still am increasingly convinced
that Santos is going to be able to just
stick this out and eventually the media
is going to move on but the stories
continue coming and I've got to talk
about a crazy one next
when you use a website or an app they
are usually sending a ton of your
personal information to social media
companies and advertising companies and
data Brokers and these companies have a
disturbingly accurate understanding of
who you are and what you do online and
it's all because in part they can see
your IP address on your computer and
your phone even when you use incognito
mode and the way to protect yourself is
to use a VPN that will hide your IP
address it really couldn't be more
simple you take a second to download it
you turn it on you don't need to know
anything about computers a VPN also
hides your activity from your internet
service provider which is also usually
logging what you do online the only VPN
I use is private internet access our
sponsor because it's the only VPN that
is proven in court multiple times that
they are not logging your activity and
with independent audits by Deloitte a
VPN also also makes it easy to watch
streaming content only available in
other countries and private internet
access is lightning fast for that go to
Pia
vpn.com
Pacman to get 83 off that's only 203 a
month and you'll get four months free
the link is down below